E aí
[Música]
Hum será que nós fomos generosos Será
que nós somos generosos em casa no nosso
trabalho será que nós fomos generosos
hoje quando chegamos aqui e
cumprimentamos e agradecemos as pessoas
que nos receberam Será que nós somos
generosos com os outros eu faço
voluntariado a 14 anos eu digo muitas
vezes que estão uma ativista pelo
voluntariado que eu acredito mesmo que
os voluntários podem mudar o mundo eu já
atravessei prisões juvenis bairros
sociais centros integrados de apoio à
deficiência
é mas queria muito fazer voluntariado
internacional EA verdade é que fiz em
2015 e eu fiz uma missão internacional
em São Tomé e príncipe que entre tantas
outras coisas me fez perceber o quão
egoísta eu era na minha vida durante
seis semanas através de educação
não-formal eu trabalhei todos os dias
com mais de 100 crianças e jovens uma
dessas crianças era o Celso quinto
explicável mente mudou a minha vida o
céu se tinha 9 anos era incapaz de
comunicar visualmente era extremamente
agressivo e eu percebi sabe-se lá como
que a melhor forma que eu tinha de
comunicar com os céus era através do
desenho durante dias desenhamos um para
o outro e desenhamos em conjunto
e antes de eu vir embora no último dia
antes de regressar a Portugal e eu
despedi-me deles e agradecemos tudo
aquilo que nós tínhamos construído em
conjunto E eu lembro-me até de virmos a
dizer a aldeia de ponta figo e virmos
todos a cantar EA festejar de tão bom
que aquela experiência tinha sido
É mas no final da estrada o céu se
arruma mão e falou comigo pela primeira
vez
e ele disse-me sabes Joana o que Tu
fizeste não é justo
e tu vieste cá ensinaste nas coisas
fizeste com que nós nos apaixonarmos por
ti e agora vai vir embora vai para a tua
família vais para as tuas pessoas e nós
ficamos exatamente na mesma
e foi o Celso que me ensinou agradecer e
foi o Celso que me ensinou a ser
Generosa EA perceber que é o tempo que
nos dedicamos aos outros que melhora a
qualidade do nosso próprio tempo eu
prometi que voltava quando cheguei a
Portugal a mudei muitas coisas nas
minhas na minha vida uma delas foi esta
consciência do tempo do nosso e dos
outros mas também a Constance A
constante insistência que nós temos em
estar em sítios em que não precisam de
nós
e eu digo muitas vezes e passei dizer o
quê com ainda mais força que nem toda a
gente pode fazer voluntariado uma das
organizações de referência para mim
nesta área é o movimento de Transformers
um movimento Nacional de voluntariado em
Portugal que acredita que todos nós
temos um talento o transforma de
trabalho com crianças e jovens em risco
e ensina as coisas que de outra forma
eles não conseguiam aprender uma dessas
aprendiz é a Joice quando a Joice chegou
aos Transformers e Recém Chegada a
Portugal ela trazia uma mochila cheia de
histórias de sobrevivência
é isso não quer nem nunca vai ser sobre
metodologias de ensino mas sobre a
qualidade do tempo e foi a qualidade do
tempo que os voluntários dos
Transformers dedicaram a Joyce foi este
poder das relações que fez com que ela
melhorasse a sua autoestima e dois anos
depois de ter entrado nos Transformers
passasse a ser voluntária foi o tempo
que nós dedicamos que a fez perceber que
agora era a vez dela dedicar esse tempo
aos outros os Transformers são apenas em
sítios onde devem estar e onde precisão
deles e não dos seus números os
transforma estão apenas em sítios onde é
possível perpetuar este ciclo Virtuoso
de relações Mas isso não é só sobre
voluntariado e também é sobre o trabalho
Há uns meses atrás eu tomei a inquieta
decisão de sair profissionalmente dos
Transformers
é muito porque quer ser coerente com
aquilo que eu digo que eu faço e eu
percebi que eu queria eu que precisava
dos Transformers já não eram os
Transformers que precisavam de mim e eu
tinha que estar num sítio onde eu era
mais necessária e tanto esta decisão E
hoje a minha missão é capacitar pessoas
e organizações para terem mais Impacto
impacto como este conjunto de
transformações que nós só conseguimos
alcançar Se tivermos os outros e o
benefício dos outros nesta equação 75
por cento dos milênios quer ter mais
propósito no trabalho mas muitos deles
continuam sem levantar o rabo da cadeira
há 58 por cento das organizações focadas
No Impacto tiveram um crescimento
superior a 10 por cento e eu continuo
sem perceber como é que todas as outras
ainda não fazem Será que nós estamos no
nosso trabalho estamos a ir todos os
dias trabalhar por nós ou também pelas
pessoas que trabalham conosco e pelo
propósito maior
ah e também é sobre relações nós
continuar mente perpetuamos relações que
somos trazem benefício próprio e digo
certamente que isso não é sustentável
ele que vai fazer estragos nós temos que
está num barco em que as pessoas que
estão conosco estão conosco nos dias de
sol como hoje mas nos dias de tempestade
caso contrário nós vamos afogar Mas a
nossa vida não é nem pode ser uma
Egotrip
e enquanto nós não percebemos que temos
que trabalhar para os outros que os
outros fazem parte desta equação do que
é viver Nós não vemos crescer e não
vamos desenvolver porque na verdade
e os outros somos nós na vida de alguém
e
e eu comprei a promessa de voltar a ser
Tomé e de estar com o céu se cumprir e
vou cumprir sempre porque nós não
podemos esperar que os outros façam por
nós aquilo que nós continuar mente
continuamos a não fazer por eles
obrigada por você sério e
E aí
[Aplausos]